so the big topic is this infrastructure
bill that congress
is potentially pushing through in the
next couple of weeks here
and they are claiming that they are
going to be raising 30 billion dollars a
year
for from taxing crypto as this bill gets
ironed out but even like further looking
down pike
what are you keeping your eyes on um for
the crypto community in the regulation
space well i
i think we should all be very uh
sensitive and alert to
[Music]
um arguments that cryptocurrency is
dangerous
is unregulated and i think we should ask
whenever we start hearing
lobbyists and and congressional
representative
talking in those terms who is behind
this and who is benefiting from this
i don't think we've seen a full court
press against crypto yet
but i i i am certain that it's coming
i'm fascinated to watch this because
when i was at ubs
i used to joke with the team i was like
our tech was so bad still is
um i say are like you know i guess they
raised me if you will i was there for
eight or nine years um but we're so bad
they should have died right if you want
to look at it like they are kodak in a
digital world
right but what has protected them and a
number of other industries too but this
one particular is
the moat of regulation around their
business it's a moat that protects them
i i find this really fun i don't i feel
like giggly it is fun
it is fun
welcome back to your yank speaks weekly
update featuring everybody but andrew
yang you're featuring yours truly
zach ralman and the one and only carly
riley
good to be back carl how are we doing oh
it's good to be here
always good to be back for our thursday
oh yeah today's episode's a good one
we're going to talk about simone biles
which everybody's talking about
in the olympics and we are going to talk
about
this new cryptocurrency regulation um
that is coming down the pipe yes sure
yeah
it hasn't passed yet it's potential um
proposed if you will it's not
but one of the things you want to do
it's a proposed regulation um
one of the things we want to do is talk
about honest pockets what everybody's
talking about to help you navigate it
and also talk about what
no one's talking about because we've
talked we've had a lot of conversations
on why there are narratives in our media
and want to help you navigate that's why
we're here every thursday
tuning in to this version of yank speaks
the
the the best version where he doesn't
speak that's not true or fair to andrew
but it is true in this episode glad
you're here let's dive in
simone biles she has so couple things as
of
um we're recording this on august 3rd
for
an august 5th episode when you're
listening to it um
so as of today um here's what she stands
she originally
about a week ago from today i dropped
out of the team usa
all-around team women's gymnastics
competition
and actually entered back in and got a
bronze medal
um on the balance beam individual event
but she had dropped out because
we were told mental health concerns and
eventually we learned
they were called uh she said she had the
twisties
and she just the mental wasn't right and
this has sparked
frustratingly so i think for you too
carly and for many of us
um it has sparked a very polarizing
fiery debate um
and it's been when i say polarizing it's
almost politicized which is frustrating
but you have many on the left
in particular but many are saying go on
queen we're so proud of you you're the
goat for doing this for prioritizing
mental health you're amazing you do you
and then on the right um or just people
in general are like
wow that's soft what the hell you bailed
on your country you left us
yada yadda um and this actually comes
let's call it a month or so after naomi
osaka
one of the best tennis player in the
world right now was a female tennis
player in the world
had dropped out of the french open after
she was fined for not doing her press
obligations um citing mental health and
she hates doing her press things gives
her anxiety didn't want to do it she's
like peace
so this is the pinnacle of this kind of
mental health and athletics
um conversation so well i think on the
on the on the left there you said it's
like a you do you think but it's more
than that it's a
it's a you know she's a hero it's a
there's a
narrative of like you know what she did
there was braver and
and more radical than performing and
getting a gold and then
i think it is very much the right that
is the backlash of that saying
why are we worshiping people for not
being able to do their jobs
that's stupid and everything that's
wrong with like weak liberal culture
yeah i think that's sort of your
dichotomy there and i will so i want
carly i want you to um so we had this
conversation
just casually not thinking we'd bring it
up on the podcast because i thought it
was covered well and i thought
the media was missing something was why
i insisted on us having this
conversation but i was in the
beyonce this is a growth moment for zach
because i think my gut reaction was like
the [ __ ] was like what the hell you
just bailed my country
um screw you um nothing wrong i i really
like
and respect she's [ __ ] amazing simone
biles i i respect her a lot but that was
my gut reaction and i've learned
through a conversation with a number of
people which we're going to get into um
where we probably should land as a
society not just like the opinion but
helping you guys navigate these kind of
very polarizing fierce narratives so
when you're at your cocktail parties
or tailgates or whatever and people talk
about it maybe you can be
the voice of reason so carly give us
your thoughts on i know you have
thoughts and simone biles yeah they're
there and i'll give my thoughts
sure well and i think you your initial
reaction
the comparison you gave was like look
josh allen being your quarterback for
the buffalo bills if josh allen suddenly
like
didn't want to perform at the super bowl
like
you know that's very upset yeah like you
know you know
that that was sort of your comparison
and and i
i think what's happening for people on
the right or people like yourself
is there's this feeling that the younger
generation are
like soft in general and we're very
sensitive and it's the snowflake
generation
and so like oh like we can't handle
anything and trigger warnings and this
and that
and i think there is a certain yes and i
think there's a certain
level of legitimacy to frustrations
around that i tend to be much more
sympathetic
to all of those things than i am
critical of them but i i understand that
that's like the impression and so i
think
this triggered that for the the right
and that's why they had that reaction
and for me
what was missing in that reaction is the
recognition that simone biles
is not that [ __ ] person like simone
biles has won
what four gold medals like to be an
olympic athlete your work ethic
and your perfectionism and your
commitment to grind it out
day after day i mean the woman was
sexually assaulted by her coach
and it's like out there continuing to
like
work her ass off like this person is the
polar
opposite of the kind of like
special snowflake he was like doesn't
want to work that hard who's kind of
like lazy
like isn't gonna you know thinks they
deserve to be the ceo without putting in
the work like
that is so not this person is and you
know when i think about that type of
person
like they're hurt more than anybody if
they can't perform like she has been
working for
years for these moments like
she's not making this decision lightly
or because she's like oh like i just
like
like i'm having a bad day like do you
know what i mean like this like
i'm just in my feelings like that's not
who this person is and it
feels like such a clear
misinterpretation of this woman
to lump her in in that category at all
um so that's why i just really felt like
that perspective was
was way off base and you said that and
it
opened up like like a
a bell went off or it just like clicked
in my head like oh yeah she's not
the special she like in order to compete
at that level you're up at five in the
morning every day
for decades um since you were a child
beating yourself up on the mat learning
um and to be at the top of your game
where she is
i mean many she is the greatest of all
time she's most decorated olympi
olympic gymnast of all time um so
i have five thoughts i'm gonna run down
quick oh boy
i have five thoughts um one be clear
simone biles is [ __ ] awesome
she doesn't know anybody anything she's
considered the greatest of all time
she was the last team member who was
part uh who was sexually assaulted by
larry nassar
um who was the complete scumbag uh from
michigan state university and the coach
or the trainer on the olympic team who i
can't even say what this [ __ ] did you
google him god
um but she stayed she did not have to
stay after she won
all those golds in rio in 2016. um
she stayed because she thought it would
be a good voice for
the girls who had aged out um when
they're gonna be in the national
spotlight in 2020
and then state of next year in 21 21
when the olympics were cancelled um
so she doesn't know anybody anything
she's won
seven i don't know if this includes the
most recent goal medal i think it's
eight i don't think
um but mate she's won seven olympic
medals four of them gold one silver two
bronze um a couple those are team
but um and then world champions i mean
she has one
when she's not competing in the olympics
we're not paying attention she has 19
world championships like she
is the greatest gymnast we've ever
fielded and she's [ __ ] awesome and we
should love her for it and i do
that's number one number two i think
millennials are soft i think i'm soft
myself at times
um i think our generation's a little
pandered um but i agree with you 100
simone biles is not one of them to be
calling soft yeah and what i would say
on even on that front and you know we've
this is a separate debate like you and i
debate determinism sometimes and i tend
to
i tend to a little bit err on the side
of like there is no free will
sam harris style like we are made up of
two things on that sometimes
no no well that doesn't have to be this
combo my point with this is like
i tend not to judge or blame people for
being the way that they are
right like because it's a combination of
your genetics and the way you were
raised both of which were out of your
control that like
made you such a way and so if you can't
really help the like
i just don't tend to be very judgmental
you and i disagree
i know biting my tongue i'm not going to
talk about right now but i will say this
whether we think it's our fault as a
generation or not
um mental health in the united states
objectively is getting worse
a lot absolutely especially amongst
particularly among young people so the
mental health
mental health america which is a mental
health nonprofit so probably skewing a
little bias to
they probably overcount rather under
count but oh i don't know
i don't know it's in there but i mean
how are they getting how is it getting
reported right like what is that they do
their surveys right anyway i'm not
trying to
i don't want to debate the quality of
the survey um but let's even if they're
conservative even if
even these numbers are aggressive down
they're still really terrifying
at 9.7 almost 10 percent of the youth in
the united states have severe
major depression that's one in 10 of our
young people compared to
just over nine percent last year so it's
gone up in the past
let's call it the pandemic i'm sure was
not
enough in the environment to help and if
you identify as more than one race
it's at 12.4 so it's gone higher there
um and then
the other one is 19 of adults almost 20
of adults
suffer from a mental illness so
this is bad all right we're we're
struggling so mental is a real thing
it's whether we want to call us soft or
not the fact is like we're all mentally
[ __ ] right now so
um it is a challenge and we need to take
it seriously because it's um
it's killing us in many ways um so that
was number two number three
the twisties which she talked about i
did some research on what the twisties
are and by research i mean i talked to
my friend
uh one of my best friends just had us we
just had his wedding a couple uh like a
month ago um
very fun wedding shout out yeah shout
out max saber he was a
um a college gymnast at um and his
girlfriend they met they were both
gymnasts kind of cute
um they were at william mary division
one
college gymnastics program sadly no
longer i don't believe the program
they just canceled but anyway max saber
my buddies with the college gymnast at
william and mary
division one very competitive gymnast
him and his girlfriends here's what he
had to say
he said and i'm gonna quote him quote
i'm 99
sure simone she did not didn't just give
up
in gymnastics there is something called
the twisties it's when you're in the air
and you have no
capitalized no no idea if your body is
flipping or twisting your wires get
crossed you don't know where the ground
is and you get quote
lost in the air happens to a lot of
gymnasts happen to me
with coding max he said it's really
scary and frustrating it usually takes a
while to fix
it's like the gymnast version of tiger
woods getting the yips
at the masters except he can't die from
shanking a golf ball yep
she could and i think this is such an
important point because this was going
to be the second thing i said about your
josh allen comparison
is your you know and football's even
more call it dangerous if you mess it up
than golf
for example but still you're not talking
about a situation where you can end up
snapping your neck and paralyzed like
she so clearly was making well no truly
those act like what can you
contract leave the football field
paralyzed all the time so
um well what can you contract though as
a footballer
like just if you're mentally off your it
it does not feel comparable right
well i look i i do i will say like if
your mind isn't right
gymnastics is the worst one of the worst
sports to be doing if your mind's off if
not the worst
um maybe it's like luge or other
something something like sports or
people die um people
someone died at the olympics the last
winter olympics we had right with two of
them
um on uh it was lose your skeleton
course um
so um mental is massively important and
the twisties are a real thing
if you talk to any gymnasts because
that's what we said like if you've
talked to any single person
that i've competed with they know what
the twisties are um
and so when she went back to pete in the
balance beam she actually changed the
end of her routine because she wasn't
comfortable doing this flip in a safe
way
or a dismount she said now
fourth thing is this is a very
interesting perspective i think for all
of us because simone's quote
said and she quote she quoted at the end
of the day
we're not just entertainment we're human
beings the we being athletes
and i think this is fun and i think the
internet has a lot to do with this um
but the dynamic we have between
fans and athletes and ownership and
athletes and all the pressures the tv
the sponsorships that sort of thing
that is changing we do not own these
athletes like we used to maybe feel like
we did
they don't work for us they once these
athletes in many ways have established
that they're good
or great they've established and some of
the people with time out if they
establish their dominance
and they get paid and they fulfill their
obligations of their contracts to get
paid
they can do whatever they want so you're
tiger lebron naomi osaka we're done with
serena williams tom brady michael jordan
they don't know a [ __ ]
um we are lucky to watch them play and
it's one of the things i hate
all the hate that people put on right
now lebron james
because he's whether you think he's
better or not than mj we get we could we
could have a debate on that on this
podcast but whether you think he's
better than mj or not
who cares he's up there
sit back and enjoy it because we get to
walk the plane at the same time
one of the greatest of all time to ever
do it is playing in prime time
anything we want um so
they don't owe us anything once they're
lebron james does not have to keep
playing michael jordan dropped out after
three championships he did come back was
like this is exhausting mentally and
physically
um and i don't need it it's a huge win
on every level to me that as a society
athletes can start putting themselves
first
forget whether or not we even think it's
legitimate or not
like or you know if she's sufficiently
mentally unhealthy
if she's sufficiently hard working to
deserve it like none of that really
matters like at the end of the day like
she has every right as an autonomous
individual to put herself first and i
think
she wants she wants to go be a go canoe
out in the middle of nowhere go for it
that sucks but she can do it one of the
comparisons that i think is really
valuable here is i think the the athlete
carrie strug is that her name have you
ever thought about her and i i think
it's so striking i mean
carrie struggle formed in the 1996
olympics and she heard her ankle
um and then she continued to perform she
ended up winning the gold
after she like severely hurt her ankle
during one of the events and
but it i mean she landed her last i was
a kid when this happened she landed her
last routine
and made like with the smile and then
like collapsed in pain like she was
maybe she was showing showboating who
knows from a long no she wasn't from a
longevity perspective
it actually hurt her career in the long
run to do that and what she said and i
think part of it was also being a woman
like she just felt like she wasn't
allowed to stand up
to authorities like there's this and and
i
relate to this like there's this good
girl thing that what like you know
whatever creates it like you just have
this feeling like you need to please
other people
and i think simone and naomi and these
women who are like breaking out from
that mold
and like being willing to not please
other people for the sake of putting
their own health first is such a good
message to be sending
which is why from out the gate i i loved
this move i understand though like do we
need to make people like
utter heroes for this you know the media
is hyperbolic but i i think it's
absolutely
a fantastic message to send to people
that like oh yeah
you know you get to make your own
decisions and it doesn't matter what
you know call it the grown-ups around
you or telling you you need to do etc i
mean look if you want to talk about
pressure and
like if you think you've ever felt
overwhelmed in life
imagine being a pro athlete atop their
game yes you get to play a game for a
living yes you're getting paid millions
and millions of dollars yes you're
famous as superstar and you've got all
these gifts
but it's incredibly pressure filled and
i remember watching the tiger
documentary on hbo which is fantastic
and they put immense amount of pressure
on tiger that first nike ad before he
had ever played a professional golf
tournament like an actual professional
he was still an amateur before then set
the stage for holy [ __ ] here comes tiger
now he delivered
but there's a the pressure we put on pro
athletes is is enormous and at a certain
point
they have every right to be like fu i
don't care so this brings my last point
point number five
and this is what i believe you might
disagree but i i feel pretty strong
about this
number five it is okay
to be disappointed and that's where i've
like you know that i mean you vilify
them but it's okay
like to your analogy you're talking
about i thought if josh allen led the
bills to super bowl
and on the day of game day he's like i
can't see straight i can't throw the
ball straight i'm going to get hurt out
there i'm going to hurt the team
and he dropped out and he said i'm not
playing today i would be devastated i'd
be mad i'd be angry
disappointed but i'd be happy he's safe
but i would be really bummed and the
better analogy is probably tom brady
because he's actually the goat and he's
already won
six seven championships whatever it is
if he went to a super bowl to win the
eighth
um and he's like i'm gonna get hurt out
there i don't feel safe
i would feel so disappointed about the
path fan but
he doesn't owe me [ __ ] um and
we all i mean i think it's un-american
to not want
to go watch simone biles kick
everybody's ass like she's so
good she made up her own flip it's
called the biles like that that's
we all wanted to watch that are you okay
to be disappointed about the about not
being able to
play that's different than like acting
that out on her but being angry for sure
agreed but i also felt like it was there
was a sense that people were like
this makes her even better or how dare
you ever doubt the
the queen i do think it makes you better
because again she's
setting a really good example i agree
with that young people everything we
just talked about of course it it's it's
a wonderful thing that
adds layers together when she's a role
model being disappointed
you didn't get to watch your favorite
athlete play
is not an excuse to call her soft
because that's inaccurate
and that's kind of the big one here like
i think they're judging her or
to judge her like there's a media
narrative that she's soft that's i mean
hell she had the twisties and came back
and won a [ __ ] bronze medal like are
you kidding me
um she's incredible um we do have mental
health
crisis i do think we're a little too
like me generation and like not doing
like that that's a whole nother
conversation simone bile should be above
that and i think
here is an interesting tweet
somebody was saying how is it that
mental health is an okay excuse
for a school shooter but not for an
olympic athlete
and i'm wondering your thoughts on this
the idea there being that like the right
will cry oh it's a mental health issue
as soon as you have a school shooter but
like somehow they're dismissive of
mental health issues when it's
an athlete who suddenly you know can't
perform at the olympics
do you think that's a fair accusational
level or an interesting
like point to be made well
if your point is that the right um that
our political parties
are pundits politicians or whoever the
right and left have hypocrisy then we
don't this is one of them
um if your point is to compare the two
i don't know they feel like apples and
oranges because no one's dying
and besides the athlete in a you know
olympic gymnast competition but in a
school shooting well no the point is
like okay
republicans acknowledge the existence of
mental health when it's convenient for
them
right so when they when they want to use
it to not talk about
a gun problem then mental health exists
and it's a real problem
when the left tries to suggest that's
what's going on in an olympic game
it's like uh whatever we're not going to
celebrate this and to be fair
i think i think part of the the
narrative on the right was less like oh
she's so weak
like you know ben shapiro tweeted like
i'm not gonna act like she's a hero or
like there's anything wrong with her
dropping yeah like he sort of jokes i
think
i think there was a lot of shapiro and i
always feel like that's when things have
gone wrong
yeah i don't agree i i actually i i
fully can just be an [ __ ]
i fully fully think it's great that she
did this and i think it does set a good
example but i but i
i do think that part of the reaction
that i was having was like okay why are
we
glamorizing this to the extent that we
are whatever separate i understand
i didn't like the glamorizing either but
i was proud that she was like
and i i think it actually is really
healthy now is there a is there
is there a risk that you have some
people who like use this as an excuse to
not push themselves
to the limits that they very well could
push themselves to because they're like
well i'm prioritizing my mental health i
guess perhaps
um it yeah
um um i think okay how about this if you
win you can if
you win four gold medals you can um take
a play off over here and then
here okay thanks good to go you're good
to go
you're a badass it was awesome watching
you we loved your run
um i hope you come back you're probably
good enough to do it late into your 20s
even your 30s but
who knows um and i hope she gets better
i think the twisty's our thing and i
hope she um
is able to get past him um cool okay
i'm very excited about this topic this
this no one is talking about topic which
to be fair in my world everyone or many
people are talking about it but i
recognize it in your world
like you're some like queen like special
sorry you're on the crypto discord set
up no flake [ __ ] those are the snowflake
no it's this in the new infrastructure
bill
that has been proposed in congress part
of the way they are suggesting
they will raise the money necessary to
build all of our new infrastructure and
replace all of our bad old
infrastructure
is through a new tax levied on
cryptocurrency users and um this has
raised a lot of controversy in the
crypto community largely because the
bill has been written in a way that's
like incredibly
tech illiterate shocker shocker of all
shockers congress knows nothing about
crypto or tech
um this is why you need young people in
congress who actually know what's
happening there shout out yeah
but you know whatever it doesn't matter
um or in in the presidency
so um we talked to
my good friend daschle shapiro who has
been a longtime supporter of andrew yang
he and i
met on the presidential campaign he was
a donor he helped fundraise for us he's
awesome
he also happens to be a really badass
tax attorney
who he's worked with the justice
department before and he
now works with a whole number of like
crypto whales basically and helps advise
them
on how to pay taxes in crypto
so we talked to him to ask him a bunch
of questions about how we should
understand
this new regulation being proposed what
might be coming down the pike in the
future
it was super fun it gets a little nerdy
and in the weeds
but uh yeah but for those of you
thinking like oh crypto regulations i
don't know this [ __ ] is going to matter
whether you like it or not it's going to
hit our lives you know
it's going to be a tidal wave at some
point and this is the beginning of that
so
daschle shapiro and carly and zach
breaking down the cool stuff right now
tune in check it out
all right a big welcome to daschle
shapiro
daschle i'm so excited to have you you
and i have been friends now honestly for
a while since the yang campaign uh and
i'll have you
kind of introduce who you are and what
you do but here's how i have explained
it to multiple people when talking about
you
you are a tax attorney who is really
carving out a niche for yourself
as a bit of a crypto tax specialist and
you work with a number of big crypto
players to advise them on how to do
their taxes
in this universe where the government
has offered very little guidance
about what technically you need to do
when making money in crypto
yeah so thanks carl and zach for having
me on it's a pleasure to be here
and i think that's a pretty good summary
just to give a little bit
um of background how i got here i
i after law school i went straight to
the department of justice tax division
and i was there for seven years
basically prosecuting tax cases for the
government
and uh i got into crypto early
on like 2013 2014
um and it's been it's been fun to see
how the irs and congress try
to get a handle on cryptocurrency tax
issues
a lot of what i do is trying to figure
out what the rules should be
and how taxpayers can can navigate
uncertain situations and anticipate what
the irs and congress are going to do
and and that that's always a tricky
issue
but it's it's one that's really fun
because my background's in both tax
controversy and then
financial products like equity
derivatives and debt instruments so
those two worlds kind of collide in in
decentralized cryptocurrency financial
products
that's awesome frankly you're like the
man for the hour right now
you understand complex products and
nonsense tax code yes which is what
we're navigating
right now so the big topic
is this infrastructure bill that
congress is
potentially pushing through in the next
couple of weeks here and they are
claiming
that they are going to be raising 30
billion dollars a year
for from taxing crypto can you
explain to us what's going on here what
this plan says
in layman people speak yeah so
just just to back up a little bit more
um there
there's uh probably anywhere between 600
billion and a
trillion dollars a year that represents
the tax gap now the tax gap
is the difference between revenue that
should be collected if everybody was
honest on their tax returns and then
what the situation is that we have many
americans don't fully report
and and pay all of their their gains
that they should so
the government is always looking for
revenue raisers and whenever you have a
a large bill um many many congressmen
senators say we're not going to vote for
this bill
until you can show us that you know
every dollar is paid for
so the cryptocurrency tax provisions uh
were born in in that in that need to
find
revenue to pay for the infrastructure
bill um so they're
they're they're probably you know a
small percentage of the infrastructure
bill but still
i think it's 28 billion dollars was the
revenue score they got
from probably joint committee on
taxation and that's a that's a sizable
sum and so it's
it's an important issue um the
cryptocurrency tax provision was just
uh came out i think it was last week
and it generated a lot of controversy
because
uh it was one of these provisions that's
written in the back room without
consultation from
industry participants and then okay so
it's a bunch of like octogenarian
congress people who don't understand
crypto
trying to write attacks crypto about how
to
get crypto right well apparently
apparently
rob rob portman who appears to his
office apparently wrote the language of
the bill
and he's supposedly the congressional
expert on cryptocurrency so right that
i don't know about how we're doing do we
feel safe or what
like the the bill doesn't make a lot of
sense it was as it was initially drafted
and it was it was
criticized almost immediately by
cryptocurrency industry groups and then
also rob portman who's the republican
from ohio criticized it
uh ron wyden who's a democrat from
oregon also criticized the language of
the bill and
and they've resolved to go back and fix
it
they've tinkered with the language a
little bit and
uh presumably the final language is not
going to
have the same defects that the original
language did
so understanding that there might be
changes and therefore not to harp on
this too long but
but quickly do you want to just tell us
how in this original version
they planned to get the 28 billion
dollars a year like what are they taxing
what is what is happening yeah well
basically
congress the reasonable uh thing for
congress to do here which is
which was put that was in the original
legislation
is to just say if if there's a broker
who
is is facilitating cryptocurrency
transactions buying and selling
cryptocurrency that that broker
should report those transactions to the
irs and that then the irs can
can see what what tax should be paid
hasn't been paid and so
forth and that in theory doesn't
generate a lot of controversy right
coinbase has had to turn over its
customer records
to the irs and in some sense it's good
for the cryptocurrency industry if there
are these
basic rules because then coinbase
doesn't have to worry about
getting summonses every year for its
customer record they should
they can just have a baseline that they
communicate this stuff to the irs their
customers know that
and it doesn't have to be a big surprise
every time there's a there's an
enforcement action against coinbase for
their
customer record so that part is not that
controversial the controversy came in
when the language describing who a
broker is
had very broad language that seemed to
apply not only to coinbase
or kraken or the the the known exchanges
the worlds but also
to sort of anybody that was uh sending
bitcoin to somebody else or facilitating
a payment or
or potentially even someone that wrote
some software for a platform that was
used
by people to transact in
cryptocurrencies and that was the part
that pretty much everybody said wait
this doesn't make any sense
it's unworkable everybody's going to be
subject to these reporting rules and
how can you report in on tax information
you don't even know who your
counterparty is you don't even know
you know if you're sending bitcoin to
someone um
online you don't always know who who's
on the other side of those transactions
so
it it would be uh unreasonable i think
to
to require information reporting to the
irs
for um software developers miners and
anybody that touches any aspect of
crypto and the part of the problem there
is
it's it literally can't be done right
and so what you
you end up in a situation where you
actually just shut down part of the
industry
which then you're not generating the
revenue at all right like that then
you're not getting the
money that you want to be getting
because you're just shutting down the
industry because these regulations can't
be complied with is that
right that was sort of the thrust of
what i was sensing from it that was what
a lot of industry participants were
saying that was the up
the outcry about this i i kind of find
it hard to believe that
the initial language would have passed
anyways and even if it would have passed
it it would have shut down the
cryptocurrency industry i think
it would have been i think it would have
been immediately obvious that these are
unenforceable provisions and i think
most people would have just went about
their daily business you might have had
some problems where
you know funding funding from large
investment banks
and unregulated entities might have been
difficult to obtain if there was
this cloud of uncertainty over but it
just it would have been a provision that
didn't make any sense wasn't enforceable
so it's hard to imagine
that it would have destroyed the
cryptocurrency industry but i think it
is
it would have caused a cloud over the
industry and
i'm glad it's being addressed the
initial outrage
seemed to imply that congress knew what
they were doing
and was like intentionally trying to
overregulate this and it sounds like
or that was what i interpreted it sounds
like what you're saying is this was
probably just congress not having any
idea what they were talking about and we
don't need to be too
the outrageous may be overblown because
they weren't actually trying to kill
crypto
they were just being morons like is that
uh well yes
yes and i think the interesting thing
here is that i think rob portman
he's he's described as the the resident
expert on crypto in congress and i think
he actually might have been on to
something
with this language um because he is sort
of
zeroing in on this on the fact that
there's a tremendous amount of
cryptocurrency transactions that are not
currently being reported they're not
currently subject to any regulation
and i think it i mean you don't want to
address this in a
in a revenue raiser that's tacked on to
the infrastructure bill
at the at the 11th hour it's not the
best way
way to address this but there is a real
problem that eventually congress is
going to have to
to grapple with which is what do you do
with
decentralized exchanges and exchanges
that don't have custody over
transactions i mean right now if the
government wants to regulate derivatives
and lending there's easy ways to do that
but what if
most lending in 10 years or most
derivatives in 10 years
are not being conducted through brokers
and exchanges but they're being
conducted through smart contracts
and on decentralized exchanges where
nobody has custody of those
funds and and there's no there's no
party you can look
to for enforcement or for tax reporting
it it it is a potential
big gap in the regulation and in the tax
law
and nobody i think as of yet knows what
to do with that so
i to the extent there was any genius
behind this original
provision it was sort of well we got to
start capturing
this unregulated area of commerce
but this certainly wasn't the place to
do it it wasn't the way to do it
i think if congress wants to look at
this they're probably going to need to
hold hearings
get testimony understand what the
industry looks like
and figure out what what legal and
technological solutions there might be
for the government to to get more
information on what's going on on
decentralized exchanges this just wasn't
the time or the place to do it
so my fear on this uh two questions one
about the
actual regulations but one is about the
process here my fear actually right now
is the infrastructure builds a lot of
momentum
it's finally moving you've got the
problem solver caucus behind it you have
like the rational members let's call it
of congress being like okay we're going
to find a bipartisan agreement here
um and this to your point is a
relatively
i think future implications are massive
but in the short term it's a relatively
small
thing to be hung up about but the bill
as it stands right now is that
um nothing would be implemented in the
earliest until 2023. so from your
perspective is there
is there a world where they pass this as
is or something close to it that we hate
as from the crypto community but
we can amend it change it or just change
implica implementation of it in a couple
years
when the rubber meets the road i doubt
it i really think
uh the the provision will pass though
maybe the revenue score will have to be
changed on it maybe it'll be revised
down from 28
billion to some lower amount but i i
think
there's general consensus that requiring
cryptocurrency exchanges to
to file information reports with the irs
that's a no-brainer
yeah we're requiring you know bitcoin
transactions over ten thousand dollars
to be
included in cash reporting forms that's
a no-brainer
and that the broker definition will be
narrowed
i think bloomberg reported today that uh
wyden and toomey are working on
on on narrowing the language for the
broker definition
and i think that that's going i i find
it hard to believe that this exp
that this expanded definition of broker
is going to make its way into the final
version of the infrastructure but i
guess it's theoretically possible but i
just think
um congress there there's no need to to
have such a
um a bomb thrown into the infrastructure
bill
they just need to raise some revenue
there's they probably are going to be
able to do that by
by just tightening up the information
report using the existing definition of
broker that's already in the tax code
that everyone already agrees on
and just and just getting this through
getting some more revenue attached to
the bill and getting some more
information going to the irs from
coinbase and kraken and the other normal
exchanges
my other question is so i have a good
amount of experience personally with
financial regulations i worked on wall
street for a while i took the series 7
and 66 and my cfa
and my god i take sony the wealth
management accredited advisor whatever
the hell they made me take um
and then i've worked in the
implementation of a whole bunch of
or working around or with compliance and
legal
um and this is my thought on financial
regulations i'm curious your thoughts
what this means for crypto so i think
smart regulations are needed and are
very good
right where fdic insurance a big one
knowing your customer there's some
really really important
i call it baseline stuff to be doing
financial transactions particularly when
it comes to consumer risks i think
customers
the clients need to know what they're
getting into but the biggest problem
with regulation
is that most of the time especially some
of the really complicated stuff
banks and financial institutions just
get around them
um and they what they do is they end up
lawyering up and hiring compliance
experts and handling all the extra
paperwork and nah nah
it makes it hard it makes it slower to
do business and it makes it more
expensive
and that doesn't actually frankly hurt
the bank very much it makes it like a
pain in their butt
but it hurts the consumer because it's a
commodity business frankly and they just
pass that down so what happens is the
business is slower and more expensive
for people
who actually are trying to use the
product not actually helping them avoid
getting into transactions lose their
shirt thoughts on that i mean i guess
from your perspective how would you
regulate the crypto industry because
what we love about it
there's a lot of reasons to love it
there's also a piece of why we love it
is it's not so regulated and it's a
little faster and it's
you don't have to go to chase and do
that i mean
you have the last time i waited in the
lobby of a bank for something it takes
forever so
thoughts on what we could do to regulate
this without actually hurting the crypto
community and or consumer
yeah i mean you're you're hitting on
exactly the main issue so that
this definition of brokers is a cr is a
critical one
and as you can imagine if you're an
investment
bank lobbyist right now you probably
want to tighten the screws in the
cryptocurrency industry
because when you know in the 1990s and
2000s and so forth
any any financial transactions in
america went
through a broker and they are held by a
custodian
and and that's how the regulatory system
was set up and
and and the brokers and custodians they
take a fee
on every transaction the whole industry
is set up around middle men
and women it's a whole industry set up
around middlemen and it creates
enormous fees for for for banks
and uh it gives regulators an easy place
to say oh here's the here's where we go
to look when we have questions
and and so everybody's making money off
of the system and now
cryptocurrency disrupts the system
suddenly i can do a transaction with you
zach or carly
and we don't have to pay a broker we can
do a complicated derivative transaction
or lending transaction just between
ourselves
and and do it through a smart contract
and we don't have to pay
a broker we don't have to pay a
custodian um and and so
that's very good for the consumer in a
lot of ways but you can imagine the
government and and
banks are want to say wait a second this
is an unregulated dangerous activity
we got to get back to everybody into the
traditional broker system
i don't think that's where this is going
to end up i mean now that we've
discovered a way to do
permissionless transactions without
brokers and custodians
i think there's going to be just a
tremendous pressure
on finance to go in into those areas
through smart contracts the question is
how does the government
get its claws into it and that is a
tricky one um
well because not only do you not need a
broker now for us to have that
transaction like we don't even really
need to know who each other
is to do that transaction right and so
right how do like if you can't collect
know your customer data
like how does the government possibly
get
involved is that sort of the fundamental
problem here
that that is the fundamental problem so
the government could take um
a very aggressive stance in a number of
ways one
it's like the like the language that
proposed in the infrastructure bill just
expand the definition of broker anybody
that touches anything
is a broker and and that would be that
would be difficult to implement another
another way the government could take an
aggressive stance is to look
at the controlled substances act so
the manufacture distribution and
production of controlled substances like
crack cocaine
those are those are those are all
illegal but the
also what is illegal is profiting from
the manufacturer distribution
or production of controlled substances
so if the government was to take a very
aggressive approach they could say
fine um we were having trouble
regulating decentralized exchanges but
anybody that profits from a
decentralized exchange
is engaged in these illegal activities
or in these reportable activities and
they could just try to
um bring the hammer down on anybody that
profits from the technology i think
i think that would be a really drastic
solution there's probably
ways in between but what's going to be
requires for the government to sit down
hold hearings
understand the technology talk to people
that have developed decentralized
exchanges and say
is there an easy way for us to code in
tax reporting into this decentralized
exchange like perhaps if you have a
decentralized exchange
you can have a way um to where the
government
is just is just it sort of seamlessly
getting information about the
transactions on the exchange and
everybody
that participates in the exchange knows
that that's taking place and
maybe there's some additional cost there
but you're still saving money because
you don't have to
go through goldman tax and ubs in order
to design your financial instruments
you can imagine there's going to be as
soon as the
the banking industry and in regulated
industries
wake up and realize what crypto offers
and what is currently taking place and
that more money is moving into these
decentralized exchanges
they're going to be lobbying for heavy
duty regulation of cryptocurrency or
they're going to be lobbying to make
sure they get a they get a large chunk
of these profits they get to play right
um but so we're we're still before we're
we're not at that point yet where
everyone really
i don't think congress and investment
banks are or have even
realized um what's at stake yet or
they're just starting to now
right and it's i've been joking with
carly a lot it's like the
crypto as cool as it is it's it's this
really incredible community of
like wading into myself but the way it
becomes mainstream is when my mother can
have a crypto wallet relatively easily
you shoot in her 60s
and that's never going to happen if
there's a chance my mother could be long
you know sending her money to someone
that's funding terrorism or
god knows what right um so there's a
there's there's that step
and it's not the next step but it's a
step eventually and that's when your
your players start to get involved and i
trying
the happy medium to figure out is how do
we stay decentralized
but also centralized enough to open up
to the means
and democratized right i think part of
the promise of crypto is the
democratization aspect
which you know the accessibility there
in some ways i mean it's not
technologically accessible because it's
a little complicated but it's
accessible in terms of like there aren't
the same barriers to entry as like
being an investor in traditional finance
in some ways okay i have i have
two questions one is to to prompt you to
an anecdote that if you don't
really want to share or say we can cut
um my first question which we'll lead
into a second
um there was a big tweet thread that
i think got a lot of traction as the
crypto community was starting to freak
out about
this infrastructure bill and one of the
the sort of claims in it was
that there actually isn't a lot of tax
evasion happening in the crypto
community
though that is the impression among the
government is that there's tax evasion
everywhere
you work with a whole bunch of frankly
crypto
whales in paying taxes what is your take
on how much tax evasion there really is
in the crypto community i would say it's
a similar amount of tax evasion as to
any industry
that doesn't get regular reports
um cash businesses
let's say you know local restaurants or
or taxi cab drivers that um
there's whenever you have an industry
and this is the
whole reason for this controversy in the
infrastructure but whenever you have an
industry
that all of their transactions are not
automatically reported to the irs you're
going to see
more people deciding not to report all
of what they did
in the last year to the irs um i think
there's there's a substantial amount of
tax dollars being paid on cryptocurrency
gains a lot of people
even without mandatory reporting we
still
have a pretty good voluntary reporting
system in america most americans
want to do the right thing pay their
taxes report their income to the irs but
it's probably consistent with other
industries where
the irs doesn't automatically know so
what's to stop you from
trying to not report everything the on
your honor system
which is not sustainable for the
government anyway
you have we you and i have talked
privately about this a couple times
and you you told me sort of a story that
i thought was funny
comparing trying to advise crypto people
on
how they should pay their taxes versus
advising people in other industries on
how to pay their taxes and
the uh call it like aggressive
risk-taking appetite of the different
communities
um i think that i think it's kind of
funny to to hear you talk about that
do you know what i'm what i'm saying
there oh yeah so okay so so your
previous question dealt with whether
people are being honest on their tax
returns or not
this question is dealing with whether
people are taking aggressive positions
i i i really distinguish the two in my
mind yes and they are they should be
distinguished yeah
the irs has issued clear guidance and
you're not abiding by it the second
is they haven't issued clear guidance so
it's up to you to figure out what you
want to do
right yeah so if you um if you work
as a tax professional with people in
different industries you see
there's very different cultures across
different industries if i am working
with someone in traditional finance and
they ask me how to report a certain item
on their tax return
what they want to know is how do i
report this to make sure like there's no
chance i'm going to be audited
the irs is going to challenge my
reporting pretty much
i would say about 80 or 90 of people i
talk to in cryptocurrency when i tell
them
here are the five different ways you can
report this from most conservative to
most aggressive uh
they will go with the most aggressive
and if i tell them well this might mean
you know you're going to have to like
challenge this in tax court and spend
tremendous amount of money and time
fighting the irs on this
to prove that you're right there the
response among cryptocurrency investors
almost uniformly is oh that's okay i'm i
am willing
i am willing to fight the irs and you
just you don't see that
um you don't see that in other
industries cryptocurrency investors are
very excited to uh advocate for
for more favorable cryptocurrency tax
provisions even if it
is at a huge cost to themselves and
um and their and their time and money
it's like they'd rather fight the
government i think they'd rather fight
the government to make the point
it's more about making the point to them
than it is even maximizing their own
profit because if they're fighting
in court then they're spending money on
that are most of these folks younger
males if there's there's younger males
you already have uh a very libertarian
leaning group
um people that got into cryptocurrency
are more interested in
alternatives to government control over
over everything
and then the other aspect of it is you
just have a greater tolerance for risk
because cryptocurrency investments
as opposed to traditional equity
investment or you know
working in you know used car sales or or
or other industries is extremely
risk-heavy yeah i don't think young ma
mail is really the differentiator
because you're talking about
the finance industry writ large well no
i'm like i was gonna say
for what it's worth like the textbook
case of like evaluating risk profiles
like men typically are riskier with
their money
younger men or younger people in general
more riskier with their money have a
higher risk profile and literally
there's like we have algorithm at ubs
you'd have algorithms if you were
putting
um an older female
into a riskier profile that would flag
and you'd have to go
like you'd have to give like sign off
the manager have to sign off on like
breaking
sort of risk profiles um so and this is
just
like the numbers maybe the books are
probably a little dated but
um that is what um at least a lot of the
psychological studies and studies of
wealth management have shown so
um that does not surprise me plus the
crypto community
general i think is used to things going
to the moon and losing their shirt on a
number of investments um
which for a lot of us makes it fun but
if we want to go mainstream it has to be
a little
less of a roller coaster and more of a
maybe merry-go-round
um daschle what are you as we wrap this
up like what
as this bill gets ironed out but even
like further looking down pike what are
you keeping your eyes on
um for the crypto community in the
regulation space well i
i think we should all be very uh
sensitive and alert to
[Music]
um arguments that cryptocurrency is
dangerous
is unregulated and i think we should ask
whenever we start hearing
lobbyists and and congressional
representative
talking in those terms who is behind
this and who is benefiting from this
i don't think we've seen a full court
press against crypto yet
but i i i am certain that it's coming
um as soon as uh as
ubs and goldman sachs and jp morgan
start to feel a hit to their
equity derivatives business and trading
business and soon
as more of that revenue starts going
into decentralized exchanges
and um you know lending pools and
staking
and and design your own loan design your
own derivative products we're gonna
we're gonna see a a pushback like
the likes of which you've never seen
before
in in u.s political history and we're
we're just not there yet but i think
this
little um flare-up when the
infrastructure builds a little preview
of what's coming i gotta say i like
crypto's chances
i think if like gamestop reddit bros can
bring down like melvin capital i feel
like
the entirety of like the crypto army can
fight
the rest of these institutions but but
that's maybe the underdog optimist in me
yeah i mean i i certainly i certainly
think uh crypto is here to stay
these tr it's just what is the
regulatory landscape going to look like
in 10 years
and that is that is up for grabs look
the the reason this is exciting is
because we're talking about this because
no one's talking about it
and the time to freak out is when
everybody's talking about it because it
means there are
forces at play that are going to
probably shaping the both the narrative
and the outcome
here the one corner of this that we
haven't we haven't really touched in
this conversation is also like
federal reserve and jerome powell's sort
of
position on crypto which has sort of
been evolving i don't know if you have
any thoughts on that or if you think
we'll end up with like a
cbdc that they try to use to put like
other stable coins out of business is
there is there anything on international
um central bank digital currency so like
governments issuing their own
proprietary cryptos basically um do you
have any thoughts on that daschle or is
that something we should
address as we're looking at the future
regulatory landscape of all this
yeah i think i think we're gonna see a
regulatory battle for control over
cryptocurrencies this is it's also sec
cftc um irs
and there's going there's just going to
be
a realization that this is not a fad
right now i think if you talk to most
people in government they think that
cryptocurrency is just
a speculative investment it's something
that a bunch of people made a lot of
money on
and they don't really understand it as
an alternative financial technology to
our current system
and that it represents a real threat to
regulators investment banks
and brokers custodians exchanges and
that it represents
alternative way of doing business which
is cuts out fees cuts out regulators
and nobody's really thought through how
to deal with it and i think
that realization is starting to dawn on
policymakers and regulators but we're
still in the very early stages of that
and as soon as
um more funds start flowing into
cryptocurrency and people
start playing around with the
technologies and understanding what's
out there they're going to say wait a
second we need to redesign our
our regulatory system to address this
and that's going to be a real fight
i'm fascinated to watch this because
when i was at ubs
i used to joke with the team as like our
tech was so bad still is
um i say r like you know i guess they
raised me if you will was there for
eight or nine years um but we're so bad
and we couldn't when you've got
platforms you can see how much money you
have
you can make trades instantly i can send
venmo in like there's all these instant
transactions that you happen at your
fingertips through your smartphone
technology
ignoring the blockchain and ubs is not
even close to that right and a lot of
these big banks are not i think chase
and bank of america are pretty good in
the app side and the retail side but
that's about
it um but yeah yeah
their systems are like duct taped
together yeah they're all amazing
awful but what has protected
like they should have died right if you
want to look at it like they are kodak
in a digital world right but what has
protected them
and a number of other industries too but
this one in particular is the moat of
regulation around their business it's a
moat that protects them
and so literally there for 10 years
almost and every time there was a new
tech coming like this is going to kill
us and it hasn't
and it keeps thriving even the remote
world when we all went you know during
cove everybody locked down
ubs was thriving so i am fascinated to
see
does this blow it all up or just become
part of it um
you know i think there's pros and cons
on both sides frankly because i think
having a generally regulated financial
i think our capital markets are a
financial treasure or a national
treasurer of this country that's one of
the best parts about america
um it can create some of the worst parts
too in terms of inequality things like
that but
um being able to get raise money for any
idea in the united states is great
um so i'm that's so that's what we
should all
that's that's the fun part to watch i
think it's going to be wild to see if it
bakes if
it just steps in line with the
regulatory process or
you know these big banks are bleeding
we're going to find out
i find this really fun i don't i feel
like giggly it is fun
it is fun um because they do have a
weird formal monopoly on let's call it a
commodity like investment you know all
the banks are technically the same
um technically like there's some areas
of expertise at each one but um
they charge a lot of fees so we'll see
um but daschle
i love doing conversation this while i
learn and i know very little
not very little but like the tip of the
iceberg on crypto um so thank you for
not making me feel too stupid and
teaching me
um and pleasure to be with you man yeah
thanks so much for having me on
thanks ashley
[Music]
all right daschle blowing my mind which
is great
good find carly thank you for teaching
me as always here's what i want to close
with very very quickly
conspiracy alert yo sad spirit healer
it's a sad conspiracy you need like a
tinfoil hat for you to wear
i need a tinfoil hat i need something
ridiculous but i'm freaking out so i
wanna i don't have enough research on it
but i'm planting a seed
because it's gonna i'm gonna find i'm
gonna try and get to the bottom of this
i'm gonna get to my little like
detective hat on so this is
okay what is happening the capital riots
on january 6th
there were the metropolitan and the
pentagon police departments
there were a bunch of cops and officers
that protected the capital
and since january 6th four
four of those cops have committed
suicide
and you know there weren't that many who
were there
anyway like it's not four out of the
entire us military like this was no it
was for about
100 or so in the pictures i don't think
it was 100 i mean it's probably
50 to 100 i don't they haven't released
those numbers you just kind of gather
from pictures it was like semi-defended
um but four have committed suicide
and three of them they have not released
their deaths so officer gunther hashida
was found not released the details of
their the detail of their desk
we just know they killed themselves but
we really don't know anything beyond
that
so officer gunther ishida was found dead
in his home
on thursday of last week um
was confirmed this week uh and then
hours after that announcement
the chief confirmed that a 20 26 year
old kyle defray tag
was uh committed suicide on july 10th as
well
um and then howard liebengood died by
suicide days after the insurrection
and dc officer jeffrey smith died by
suicide later the month
um in january shortly after the attack
so that's four
and my heart goes out to those families
um because that had to have been a
traumatizing experience
they are fighting over whether these
deaths were um in the line of duty
um this wait what do you mean
so the department is saying it was not
in the line of duty this was a suicide
and the families are going to argue that
it was
oh for the three years before or for all
of them
for i believe all of them are arguing
this um and they're going to probably
because it has to do with the
pension i imagine um because they get a
pension payout if you kill the line of
duty
um i don't know so is the argument so
for for folks that were found at home
dead
the argument is this was still like a
a workplace hazard essentially or that
this was a this was trauma
induced by being in the line of
or where my conspiracy theory is going
off is that there's something deeper
jeffrey epstein's [ __ ] so i don't know
any yen gang can go down this rabbit
hole dig in let me know
do you think i don't mean this by any
disrespect to families i don't wanna
make light of their deaths i'm very very
clear this is serious and it's um and
look if it's if it's just like
above board like this is just really sad
but if something fishy is going on
um i would like to get to the bottom of
it
i would like to understand it that is so
that does seem so
strange i mean you know i'm sure
obviously being a cop
tough job not trying to get political
with this or with that but
you know you can imagine a lot of trauma
ptsd that can result in suicide so i'm
sure you have a higher
rate of death by suicide among cops in
general but that does seem
like an exceptional number
and very underreported very hush-hush
well there's probably a sensitivity to
the families when you talk about three
of the four
details haven't been reported i mean
that that might be partly the families
not wanting those details out yet
to your point if they're trying to argue
that this was in the line of duty for
pension reasons for funding reasons
whatever
right they might not want details being
so this could all be normal but it could
be conspiracy
and i'm digging into it so that's what
we're leaving with you leaving you with
y'all
come back next thursday maybe i'll have
more info on that we'll talk about
something else that's awesome
enjoy your week folks talk to you soon
[Music]
you